I want to try get
30 30 gr of protein per per main meal
right and I get that from tofu Tempe
legumes you know beans chickpeas um
lentils some nuts and seeds um I'm
trying to eat carbohydrates at all my
meals as well and I like to get it from
whole grains um and then a big big base
this is where the volume comes I can get
my volume that fills me up from the
lower calorie density you know nutrient
dense leafy greens cruciferous
non-starchy vegetables if you stick to
that and you eat 3 meals a day you
pretty much going to be good but if you
really want to bulletproof it you know
I'll take a protein um supplement after
workouts just because I enjoy it I
actually like the flavors and I can make
a smoothie or a you know like a sort of
like protein ice cream or something and
that's the enjoyment